bonjour arnaud lapointe merci de
répondre à nos questions en direct sur
arte france
samia ghali a dit ce matin que le
conseil scientifique je cite conforme
elle dénonce le diktat des nantis
parisien est-ce que marseille sera
devenue une ville peuplée
d'irréductibles gaulois qui résiste
jusqu'à elle l'est devenue l'at elle pas
toujours été non mais je crois qu'il ya
une dimension de fond une dimension de
forme c'est à dire que c'est pour moi
légitime que on est à un niveau de débat
qui soit échelle locale
c'est vrai que dans ses propos il est
logique que les élus marseillais les
parties prenantes de la cité phocéenne
puisse porter le message du local de là
à ce que ça prenne une forme très
comment virage très rebelle d'un conseil
scientifique autonome ce jeu j'ai plus
de doute sur le fond que sur la forme
mais il est vrai et en cela il a raison
il est vrai que beaucoup de marseillais
et d'entrepreneurs marseillais ont une
crise de confiance
finalement par rapport aux autorités
publiques et se demande si le principe
de précaution ne va pas trop loin par
rapport à leur principe de réalité à eux
qui est une réalité économique à un
moment où ils sont fortement en danger
et la question de la survie se pose pour
beaucoup de ces bars et restaurants vous
parler d'économie justement vous êtes
docteur en sciences économiques ce
conseil scientifique parce que c'est pas
un moyen finalement de sauver le tissu
économique de marseille en tout cas
c'est un bon moyen de se faire entendre
c'est à dire que à mon avis plus qu'une
vocation sanitaire ce conseil
scientifique doit être un moyen de
porter la parole des marseillais est
d'éclairer finalement les instances
nationales de la réalité locale donc en
cela moi je vois plus dans cette
tentative de création d'un conseil
régional je vois plus la volonté de
porter la parole du tissu local plutôt
que de s'opposer aux grandes décisions
sanitaire parce que de vous à moi je
voit pas bien quelle légitimité aurait
ce conseil et surtout quelle serait sa
capacité d'action ça veut dire que
marseille serait pas dans son rôle de
vouloir prendre ses propres décisions
sanitaire avec ce conseil scientifique
moi je ne crois pas je crois pas que
marseille puisse créer un état dans
l'état
en revance que les représentants de
marseille porte la parole
les tissus local marseillais ça oui mais
je le vois plus comme un organe
consultatif plutôt que les six heures le
conseil scientifique dont le conseil
scientifique nationale dont celui ci
dont le professeur didier raoult et a
brièvement fait partie est ce qu'il est
déconnecté du terrain est trop parisien
en cas de désaccord avec le conseil
scientifique par parisien qui aura le
dernier mot par exemple est-ce qu'ils
apparaissent de cacao de cacophonie
comme ont souligné certains élus aient
le dernier mot il sera de toutes façons
à l'état donc je pense que c'est ton à
risque d'aller dans cette rébellion l'a
en revanche à par rapport à la question
que vous posez est ce que le conseil
scientifique nationale est déconnecté de
la réalité
oui probablement un peu c'est à dire que
me permets pas de juger de la réalité
scientifique sanitaire mais mais je
pense que les décisions qui sont prises
ou non la situation sanitaire sont
complètement déconnectés de la réalité
économique de terrain est ce que est ce
que les gens réalisent qu'une partie des
restaurateurs et des bars sont au bord
de la faillite que on a un impact
terrible sur les métiers l'hospitalité
de la restauration qui ont tenu
grassoise aide de l'état pour partie qui
ont tenu pendant confinement et qui
espérait beaucoup un retour à l'activité
normale pour attraper leurs pertes et en
fait on est en train de faire du report
de dettes du report de déficits et
on est au bord de la catastrophe
économique alors est-ce que marseille
avec ses conseils scientifiques
n'ouvrira pas un peu la boîte de pandore
est ce qu'on peut voir fleurir un peu
partout des conseils scientifiques comme
ça à lyon lille bordeaux
bah je crois qu oui ça serait ce serait
d'une certaine manière faire
jurisprudence
moi il me semble plus sage de demander à
être entendue de porter la réalité de
terrain et de rentrer dans une logique
de dialogue plutôt que de contestation
merci arnaud la con d'avoir répondu à
nos questions jean périssé vous êtes
docteur en sciences économiques diplômé
en sciences politiques et professeur de
management à la cass business school de
marseille